MALE SPEAKER:
Hello, everyone, and
welcome to our third
installment of the Pride Series
in Mountain View.
We have today with
us Samual Brinton,
and we'll be talking
about ex-gay ministries
and conversion
therapy, which I like
to think Sam is one of
my closest role models
just because of how far he
has come with this story
and sharing that with
others, and as a survivor
myself, knowing how
far you can come.
I met him, I believe,
four years ago now
and found myself from
a super small town
in Iowa all the
way to Google here.
Definitely a testament
that things can change
and how far you can come.
With that, Samual Brinton.
SAMUAL BRINTON: Thank
you so much, Charles.
Awesome.
It is great to be
here with you today.
I will probably be
walking back and forth
a bit, because standing
in one position for me
is little bit weird.
Today we're going to be
talking about-- I have a title,
but it's a work
in progress-- "You
Can't Change What
We Never Chose."
Today, I'll be talking
about conversion therapy.
Conversion therapy is also
known as reparative therapy
or sexual orientation
change efforts,
or whatever we want to call it.
In actuality, pretty much
what I'll be talking today
is about the torture that
we have legalized here
in the United States and in 48
states, which is a huge problem
and something that
we're hopefully
going to be able to address.
I'll try to tie-in a little bit
of how activism and academia
have been coalescing
in these spaces,
and we'll have a lovely journey.
As we go through today, if
you ever have any questions,
feel free, of course, to ask.
We'll also definitely
have a lot of time
for questions at the end.
It's very, very
important to me that I
get through this
experience and then
we discuss what we think
we're going to do next.
Please have questions
ready because it's
really awkward at the end if
I'm standing here looking pretty
and you don't have
any questions.
Let's get started.
Initial questions--
who is this person?
Hi, I'm Sam Brinton.
I was a graduate student at MIT.
I just graduated two weeks ago,
I just got two Masters'-- one
in nuclear engineering, and
the other in technology policy.
I work in nuclear
waste management
and disarming nuclear weapons
are my two areas of expertise,
which I know you
probably haven't seen
very many nuclear engineers in
heels before, but this is OK.
We're going to work
on this together,
and soon, the entire
nuclear industry
will be fashion forward.
Why am I talking?
I'm talking because this is
an important issue that's
affected me personally.
But at the same time,
I recognize that even
without a personal
investment, this
is something that is being
silenced in our community.
For example, I live
there in Massachusetts.
For 10 years, we
have had the ability
to have same sex
marriages, yet we still
have the legality of
converting our children
from gay individuals to
straight individuals.
That is still a
completely legal practice
in Massachusetts
and 47 other states.
While we may be
having a great debate
about a lot of
other issues, this
is something that I see as
a very important space that
is not getting enough attention.
What am I going to
learn in this session?
You're going to
learn a little bit
about the history of
conversion therapy.
You're going to learn a little
bit about my experience, which
is one experience.
I should be very,
very, very clear.
One experience of many
different types of experiences.
You'll also learn a
little bit about how
we're addressing this currently.
It's kind of a history
lesson, a sob story,
and then a really
happy story of how
we're going to make it better.
You're in the wrong room,
and should you leave,
the exits are located
to the rear end.
It's totally OK if
during this conversation,
it gets a little too
emotional and you
feel like you need
that space to walk out.
I work a lot with survivors.
What I'm going to
be going through
is in front of you
rehashing of my story, which
can be very traumatic.
It's very possible that at some
point during my presentation,
I might start crying.
That's OK, because guess what?
Humans cry.
This is a thing.
I want to make sure that if
you're a survivor in this room,
I don't know what you look
like-- because guess what?
Not all survivors have
as good fashion as I do,
but other than
that, this space is
that survivors don't
look any different.
Just because as the LGBT
community doesn't necessarily
stand out, and we're
in all communities--
survivors are in
all communities.
We have to recognize that
some of you in this room
may also be that.
Feel free to go out.
Is he ever going
to stop talking?
I've been told I only have
so much time with you all,
so I'm going to try
to stop talking.
It's a work in progress.
I also definitely tend
to go off on tangents.
So if I end up on a
tangent, I'm going
to try to pull myself back.
But we'll see where it goes.
If you haven't guessed, I'm
also moderately energetic.
If you need to be
boring, just let me know,
and I can sap all energy
and be monochromatic.
That's pretty much where
we are for the intro.
I use humor a lot in order to
get through this experience.
History 101-- if you don't
know about the LGBT community,
we've always existed,
so that's step one.
Step one, the world is created.
Gays make the world
a little bit better.
Step two.
Then over time because a
lot of different features,
we were classified
as a mental disorder.
In that experience,
I tend to bring up
Sigmund Freud because he's
a well known psychoanalyst.
In that space, Sigmund Freud was
influenced about homosexuality
by another researcher
who will go unnamed
at this point who believed that
homosexuals could be changed
to heterosexuals
by simply replacing
the testicles of a
straight man and putting
those testicles into a gay man.
Question one-- how many straight
boys are raising their hands
and are like, give my
balls to the gay dude?
Please give my balls
to the gay dude.
Not really a huge population
that are doing that.
Two, sanitation in
surgery at the time
is not the highest quality, so
we're losing a lot of patients
not to heterosexuality,
but to infection.
After a while, this practice
was thankfully ended.
is thankfully ended.
We over time start to
realize that maybe it's
not a useful process, and
maybe homosexuality itself
isn't the mental disorder.
We go into those
spaces and we keep
trying to get it all
a little bit better.
As soon as we are
no longer classified
as a mental disorder,
predominately religious
organizations step up being
like, nope, still a problem,
still needs to be fixed.
A majority of conversion therapy
spaces did occur in the past.
I'm not negating that fact.
But they're still
occurring, and that's
why we're still addressing this.
But the reason that
they started to occur
was because religious
organizations
were like, we can still help
you get away from this disorder.
Those organizations
include Love in Action,
which tends to run the
large campus to help train
individuals on how
to be straight.
Exodus International, which was
a large umbrella organization
of a lot of practitioners
trying to help
connect parents to a
way to help their child.
Then you have NARTH,
the National Association
for the Research and
Treatment of Homosexuality.
NARTH is the MIT of
conversion therapy science,
i.e. tries to bring in
research into this area.
If an individual from NARTH
is in the room, I apologize.
I'm going to bash your
field for a pretty much
the entire conversation,
so good luck.
NARTH, highly discredited,
not scientific.
You're here at Google.
I will allow you to
do your own research.
Most of their research has
obviously been conversations
right as a person leaves
an ex-gay facility.
Well, if you just paid tens of
thousands of dollars to change,
you're likely right
after you leave
to say yes, it's had
some type of effect.
If you don't do a
follow up and you
don't watch these
individuals, obviously, we're
never changed, and
have actually come out
to live healthy,
productive LGBT lives.
You don't really get the
research going forward.
A lot of people
have, thankfully,
discredited their work.
You also have organizations
like the American Psychological
Association, which
in 2009, stated
that all of these things that
we were doing were just wrong.
This is no longer
a mental disorder.
Not only is that true,
but the health impacts
of this conversion
therapy is intense
on these poor individuals.
Also discredits a lot
of NARTH information
that this is not an
actual conversion.
These are not really conversions
of people, and as well,
speaks about the
health impacts, mostly,
which were most important.
You also had individuals
like Spitzer,
who in their original
research stated
that there's these NARTH spaces.
These individuals have
the ability to change.
And thankfully, in 2012,
comes back out and says,
this was not a strongly
scientific space,
and I pretty much recant
what I've said before.
I apologize for
science trying to be
used to harm these individuals.
If we go on into the most
what I would call modern age
conversion therapy,
in general, these
have been led by
religious organizations.
I need to be very,
very clear right now.
I am myself a QPOF-- a
Queer Person of Faith.
I was praising my Jesus on
Sunday, and it was wonderful.
Really good music.
That's really important
for me, but it's not
important for everyone.
But I do want to recognize
that what I'm going to say
may sound anti-religious, but is
not in any way, shape, or form.
It is simply that a minority
and loud voice in that community
is getting too much attention
that these processes are
actually valid.
The majority of
the faith community
is starting to recognize
that this is not
something we should be
doing to our children.
I want to make sure to
make that association.
However, for example,
the Mormon church
has one of the more
famous examples.
There was a number
of individuals
who were attending Brigham
Young University in Provo,
which is a beautiful city.
These individuals were
found out to be gay,
and the university told them,
you will either convert and go
through this process, or we
will kick you out of university.
In case you haven't figured
out, that's called coercion.
That's not a really
good scientific process
for getting your
candidates for your study.
These individuals go through
this process-- electroshock,
all types of very, very
excruciating experiences,
similar to if you ever have
seen the movie "Latter Days."
It kind of captures
parts of this story.
Once they come back out,
many of these survivors
later would commit
suicide or die
because of the mental trauma.
The university originally
ignored that it ever
happened, saying
that nope, we never
put these people through
anything like this.
Once it's pretty
much scientifically
proven that there can't be this
many stories of this experience
without some corroboration,
the University says, well,
they volunteered.
We have this space, which is a
central tenet of the conversion
therapy question
of, well, sorry.
They decided that they
wanted this change.
Coercion is never
a form of want.
For myself and my
story, I was forcibly
coerced into this space.
Especially if you're a minor
or a student in college,
you're just starting to develop
your sexual orientation.
You're just starting
to figure out
how you actually
relate to this space.
Being told that there's
this easy way out
and that it's not
going to be hard,
don't worry-- with enough
prayer, you'll be fine is a lie
that we're telling our children
and can be very, very, very
harmful.
We need to recognize that
there may be faith spaces that
don't align with
sexual orientation,
but that for many
of us, we have found
a community of sexual
orientation and faith together.
I'll go through a
few trigger warnings.
I'm about to go into my actual
personal story in this space.
One, if you're a survivor,
highly graphic content.
I will be going through
all of my experience,
so if you are a survivor, I
want to mentally prepare you
that this is my chance
to kind of share
with a non-survivor
community, so I'm
going to lay it all
out on the line.
There will be multiple
trigger warnings,
for example-- abuse,
suicide, a lot
of anything with electroshock.
Also, I have already warned
you about my emotional state.
I'm finally getting
to the point where
I can get through this story
without completely emotionally
breaking down, and I will have
a lot of lemon sorbet tonight,
which is my coping mechanism
to get through this.
But I want to warn you that
especially since we have people
watching online and this
will be recorded, that if I
do emotionally
breakdown, that's OK.
I will get through it.
I'll probably stop the
story, and we'll just
move onto the next section,
because guess what?
It's my story to share when
I want with who I want.
I'm sharing it
with you because I
want to inspire you to do
something good with a story.
You are free to
take it out, but I
ask that you do provide
these trigger warnings people
as you share the story,
because you don't know,
again, what a
survivor looks like.
Let's get started with
[HIGH PITCHED VOICE]
some of my favorite
pictures in the world.
I was talking high,
sorry. [LOW PITCHED VOICE]
Some of favorite
pictures in the world.
So that's me as a baby.
I'm adorable.
If you haven't noticed,
you can kind of see it,
but my hair pretty much matches
the color of that red fire
truck.
My mom loved to do this
with me as a child.
She would put me up
next to a fire truck,
and you couldn't tell where
my hair stopped and the truck
began because I literally
had that bright red hair.
So I just consider this
going back to my roots.
This is not my
actual hair color.
Just letting you know.
Also, I wanted to
point out my family.
That's my father.
Me and my sister.
Obviously, both of us
have such wide smiles
that we can't ever
seem to show our eyes.
And then my baby brother,
12 years younger,
who's getting to the
same level of smiling.
I grew up as a Southern
Baptist missionary,
traveling to South America
and across the globe
trying to share the love
of Christ with others.
My passion for that was mostly
through humanitarian spaces.
Obviously, as a child, I
recognized the importance
of faith, but I was definitely
doing it more of a, oh,
we're doing this good
work in a village.
We're teaching a language, or
we're giving them written word.
A lot of these kind of spaces.
We moved back-- I'm not
going to go through all
my missionary life
because we only
have so much time-- we
moved back to Florida.
You may be wondering why
there's a random Playboy
on this screen--
because I adore Playboy.
The missionary child has a very
limited scope of information.
We didn't, one, have
Google that we really
accessing at that time, and
two, we were very much censored.
If any of you grew up in
the evangelical community,
the largest thing that
I got to experience
was Veggie Tales,
which are large,
singing vegetables about Christ.
I will not go into
the song right now,
because if anyone
else sings it, we'll
all start singing it together.
It'll be really
creepy, and you'll
be like, what do they drink?
Anyway, imagine moving
from Christian vegetables
to a Playboy magazine.
That's a large, large
social jump for a lot of us.
We'd found one out in the trash.
All of the boys start
getting excited.
I consider myself so
holy and righteous
that it doesn't
affect me, and started
praying for the sinners,
starting praying.
Go to my parents, and my
dad's very proud of me
that I didn't react.
Because I told them everything,
I look at my father, and I say,
yeah, but sometimes
I have those feelings
when I think about Dale.
Because it was a natural thing
that literally came out just
like that like.
Like, you tell your parents
when you sin sometimes.
Because you know what?
I have problems too, Dad.
I'll pray for myself,
and I'll work on it.
I thought it was totally OK to
have it with Dale, just like it
would be OK to
have it with Sarah.
Doesn't everyone just
have these feelings?
My dad's face dropped.
Dale, if you haven't
guessed at this point,
is a male identified individual.
I sometimes identify as male.
At that time, I was.
It was a very interesting space
of my father's face dropping,
him coming toward me,
and then I woke up
in the emergency room of the
mission organization, which
was just down a few floors.
My father had
knocked me out cold.
I would get beaten
a few more times
before my parents
would finally recognize
that maybe this wasn't working.
This wasn't quite the space
that we wanted for him.
We moved into
conversion therapy.
I still don't know how
they found out about it.
It could have been
googling for it
but again, I don't remember
if they did that back then.
Or it could have just been
hearing about it at the church.
We showed up to the
conversion therapy site,
and it's across from a
beautiful, pristine, blue lake,
which is useless in
Florida for finding it,
because there's like
a million lakes.
We walk into the room.
There on the coffee table are
seven bibles all in a stack.
To which, I look up at my mom
with the largest grin, which
you've already seen previously,
before saying, oh my gosh.
He loves Jesus just
as much as we do.
I was so happy
that someone would
be just as excited as I was.
My mom looks down and
says, yes, yes he does.
He loves Jesus just
as much as we do.
That would begin my
conversion therapy experience.
It ranged from me being
told that I was the only
gay left in the world, that
the government had come through
and killed off every other
single gay in the entire globe.
And that somehow,
myself and a few others
would every once in
awhile get through.
But that was enough
work, it'd be OK.
Some of you in this room,
a mildly intelligent group,
are like wow, Sam, how did
you get through to MIT?
Because you're obviously the
biggest ditz I've ever met.
Imagine, again,
where I've lived.
I've lived in places where
the government coming through
and killing off a group of
people, totally normalized.
I've watched people shot
right in front of me.
That was a part of my childhood.
The government coming
through and killing people?
Sure.
Obviously, that's something
that could happen.
That's also a really great way
to keep a person in the closet.
If you think the government
is going to kill you,
you pretty much
don't tell anyone.
We then moved to the
space of not only
did the government
want to kill me,
but the reason they
wanted to kill me
was because the gays had
brought AIDS into America.
That was why the
government was purging us,
was they were trying
to save the population.
I've been to South Africa.
I've worked in an
AIDS orphanage.
I know that this
is an actuality.
I know this is a possibility.
I didn't understand
why they had AIDS
because they didn't
seem to be same-sex,
but I'd seen what this
horrible disease could do.
So now I'm dying internally,
the government wants to kill me,
and then the next few weeks
were about how God hated me.
The last straw, this
beautiful central tenet--
I know that I'm
probably harping on too
much, but for a child like
myself, that was what I could
hold onto was that at
least God loved me still.
That was taken away from me.
God hated me, we went
through the verses,
and now I understood that
these abominations were myself.
We'd always talked
about abominations.
But Jews were abominations.
Catholics were abominations.
People who wore white after
Labor Day were abominations.
Baptists are very
good at judging.
I wonder how I
turned out like this.
We're very, very
good at judging.
Because I had
become that space, I
didn't understand that I
was one of those people now.
Once that connection was made,
emotionally, I am devastated.
This is where the suicide began.
This is where I do
prove I'm a ditz.
I'd heard-- I don't
know where-- that if you
took a lot of pills,
you would die.
Instead of two
Advil, I took three.
I laid down on my bed,
definition of princess.
Crossed my arms over
my body, and just
prayed that God would
just take it away,
like, I'm so sorry that
I failed you so badly.
I woke up without a
headache and realized
that it wasn't going to work.
I tried really hard.
For the next month, I
would wake up praying
and go to sleep
praying and eat praying
and cry and sob with my
parents, telling them
I was doing everything I could,
but I just didn't understand.
I was too honest.
I was honestly
trying to figure out
why it wouldn't go away, why
this feeling wouldn't go away.
Then we moved into
physical therapy,
where my hands would
be either placed
in ice or ice cubes placed
on them while pictures
of men touching other
the men were shown.
So I would associate
that freezing cold
with a touch of another man.
To this day, is still
hurts to touch another man.
Heating coils would be
wrapped around my hands,
and they'd be
turned on with heat
when pictures of men
touching men were shown,
turned off when pictures of
men touching women were shown.
I'm supposed to
associate that it's
going to be horrible
if you touch a man,
but it's going to be OK
if you touch a woman.
If you have ever taken
a psychology class, what
they were doing to
me was Pavlov's dogs.
It culminated in
electroshock therapy.
Electrodes were
attached to my fingers
and then shocks were
given to me while I
was shown pornographic images
of men having sex with men.
This would be later on-- my
first kiss, within seconds,
I would puke just simply
from the excruciating pain
of remembering what
that felt like.
To this day, any male-identified
individuals in this room
or whoever I meet, I
tend to pull them in
to hug me because I
don't want to have
them be the one that hurts me.
I want to hurt myself
when I touch them.
It's also a very
important space for me
that they feel OK to touch me
because the concept of being
a leper is even worse.
Recognizing what this
has done to our children
has complete-- I was
in the exact zone
that I was mentally developing.
So for the rest of my
life, I will probably
have some of these effects.
It's getting way better.
I happily have had boyfriends.
I've happily moved to
a lot of these spaces
where I can deal with
this, because I'm
a champion in those zones
that I'm able to move forward.
But those lasting
effects are eternal.
I finally realized that
there's nothing left.
I tried a few other
suicide attempts,
and finally, say goodbye to
my family-- my sister, excuse
me-- go to the roof, and I'm
about to jump because I just
can't deal with it anymore.
Suicide's a sin, but let's
be honest, at this point,
there's nothing
really that much worse
than what I'm at this point.
My mom finds me, tells me
that she will love me again
if I will just change,
which is not a thing
to say to your child who
is about to commit suicide,
just for future reference.
Then, because I'm moderately
logical-- thankfully,
not ditsy at this
point-- I turn and say,
he did it, meaning
God had changed me.
Because I looked down,
I was like-- if I
don't die with this fall, it's
going to really hurt a lot.
I'm not going to
do this anymore.
I realized that lying
was a bad thing,
but it was all I could
do at this point.
Instantaneously, whoosh.
Everything stops.
We don't talk about
any of my past.
It is as if everything has
changed, and we're now in Oz.
Everything is beautiful.
Funny that we said Oz.
We would then move to Iowa
where my dad had grown up.
I would go to high school.
I would convince my parents
let me go to public high school
so I could be a missionary
to the other kids.
I would do most of my schooling
at home and then move over.
It was a beautiful moment.
It was this space that I
could finally experience.
I still thought
the government was
going to kill me if I came out.
I'd never met another
gay individual.
I'm in middle of Iowa
where the only person
that I heard that
was gay was literally
dragged behind a truck
by the football team.
This is not something that
I'm experiencing, ever.
We never, in all of my
years of high school,
ever mentioned the
word "gay" once
in my school, which
is fascinating to me.
I'd now look at
their current spaces
and be like, that
would never happen.
But in my space, it was
completely normalized.
Decided to be a nuclear engineer
because my parents wanted
me to go to Kansas State
University in Kansas--
excuse me.
My parents wanted me to go to
Pensacola Christian College.
Pensacola Christian
College didn't
have nuclear engineering.
I chose nuclear
engineering so I wouldn't
have to go to Pensacola
Christian College.
Probably a better reason to
choose nuclear engineering
than to not go to Pensacola
Christian College,
but it worked really
well, and I liked it,
and it was a good
academic challenge.
Went to university
and would later
come back out after
finding a community, which
we can talk about more
in the questions space,
but then would start talking
about the story thinking
that other people had gone
through exactly what I'd
gone through and started
realizing that people
like Charles and others had
gone through this experience.
That I wasn't the
only one who had
gone through these pains
and these sufferings.
That's why we work on this, is
because although that is one
story, and there are
thousands of others,
they're all that wretched mental
torture, which is completely
legalized in this country.
Again, I can't fathom it.
We would never allow this
to happen to prisoners,
and yet we do it to
our own children.
This is the space that I'm at.
Let's talk about how
we get that to stop.
One, we get professional
organizations on our side.
If there's an APA in
the country-- except
for the podiatry
association, or something,
I don't know-- hahaha, heels.
They are against
conversion therapy.
It is blatantly been shown
by professional organizations
to not work and
be very damaging.
Great.
So we have professionals
on our side.
Social workers, medical doctors,
psychologists, psychiatrists,
everyone says this is a problem.
The challenge is that
just because you're
a professional organization
doesn't mean that you actually
have control over
the entire situation.
These organizations actually
came out awhile ago saying it,
but yet, it was still
massively practiced
because a lot of people were
just ignoring this fact.
One, we have special
organizations on our side.
The problem is we don't
have mass education.
No one knows that this
is still happening,
and so because of it,
we're not actually
making the major
strives that we need,
which is where you come in.
A lot of my friends will
every once in a while
invoke issues-- both
in nuclear weapons
and in conversion therapy,
be like, the 1980s called.
They want their issue back.
And I'll be like, 2014 called.
Still an issue.
We still have many
nuclear weapons.
In case you didn't know, 23,000
nuclear weapons in the world.
Trying to disarm them, but
it's a slow-going process.
We also have
thousands of students
who are put through
this conversion therapy
every single year.
The National Center
for Lesbian Rights,
which I'll cover a little
bit more in the future,
is starting to
work on this issue
and starting to really delve
into why this is a problem.
But a lot of other major
LGBT organizations are not.
This is my call
to them, that they
need to start telling
these stories.
They need to start working
together as organizations so
that we can actually
make a difference.
Because if we can be
married for 10 years
but can still electrocute
our kids, something's wrong.
This is why we need more
of this educational space.
We also need to protect those
who've gone through this.
For myself and for
others here at Google
and for other survivors
across the country,
we are highly prone to suicide.
Let's talk a little
bit about why.
You've just gone through
conversion therapy
with a therapist, so
who are you supposed
to talk to about your
feelings once you're
done with conversion therapy?
The person who was
horrifying traumatic to you?
Going into a mental health
situation for me was horrible.
I couldn't go into--
I can't sit on a couch
opposite of a therapist.
It took me years to
be able to do that.
In the last three
months, I've finally
been able to sit on the couch
opposite of another male
while we talk about
mental health.
It took me that long
because I couldn't
experience all of
the trauma again.
We have this major issue
that we have no one to go to.
Our partners--
again, I told you,
I puked a few seconds after
my very first gay kiss.
That's not a very great
way to start the date,
was just letting you
know of that right now.
Boyfriends have had to
not be able to touch me
when I'm crying.
That's the moment
you want to be there
for your friend and your
partner, and you can't do it.
We feel very alone.
Because of that, it
obviously leads--
the APA and others have said
to substance abuse and suicide
and major, major mental
health connection problems.
I highly recommend, in
case you don't have it
in your repertoire,
the Trevor Project.
We work for the Trevor Project.
They know about survivors.
They know about how
to deal with us.
Just telling us that
it's going to be OK
and that it's OK
to be gay is not
the best system
for a person who's
just been told for years that
it's not OK to be themselves
and that by even
using the word gay,
they're going to
eternal damnation.
You probably shouldn't
use some of those terms.
They've worked
with these phases,
and they're really good
helping us deal with it.
Connecting a survivor
community to say
that you're OK as
you are, and we're
going to work with you to
find you the mental health
that you need is a
very important space.
Then we have to work to
actually make it stop.
Not only do you educate
about the history
and work with the
survivors, which
I consider more important, but
you also have to make this end.
Exodus International-- the
group that I told you about,
that I was telling
you earlier on--
has thankfully been shuttered.
It has been changed over in part
to the Restored Hope Network.
Umbrella organizations
are tough,
because when you
tumble the head,
you still have all the
babies, and they still
keep flying all over
doing evil damage.
There's more networks that are
going to keep coming forward.
Until you start actually
addressing all of those sites,
you're going to
have these problems.
You also have organizations
like Focus on the Family
or the Family Research
Council, which
produces books like, "How to
Make Men be Like Men" and "How
to Make Women be
Like Women," which
may seem to only be
a slight challenge,
but it's obviously
conversion therapy.
This is blatantly
telling you, you're not
fitting into the gender
identity or the gender spaces
that we expect of
you to act like,
and therefore you
must be changed.
In case you haven't
figured out, I don't always
fit into the gender identity
and gender expression spaces
that I was assigned at
birth, but that's OK,
because I'm being myself and
I'm OK with those spaces.
We have to be able to create
those self-centering spaces.
We also have individuals
like Michelle Bachmann.
I realize this is now
recorded, so there
goes my political
career, but anyway.
You can't really see it,
and I apologize for it,
but Crazy Eyes, as I lovingly
referred to her as-- obviously,
if you haven't guessed,
ran a presidential campaign
and actually did pretty
well, whose husband
practices conversion
therapy on individuals.
It's not like this is the
most hidden organization
and not-talked-about thing.
It is blatantly known that
Michele Bachmann's husband
practices conversion
therapy, which
means that we had a
presidential candidate who
the first "lady" would have
practiced conversion therapy.
That's a problem.
When it's not called out for
what it is, that's a problem.
This is why we're needing
each of you to be involved.
Here's what we need you to do.
The ultimate goal is
that anyone under 18
should not be able to
undergo conversion therapy.
It should be outlawed.
Some of you are like,
whoa, what about over 18?
I can't stop you from eating
as many Big Macs as you want.
You can do it.
It's not good for you.
I can tell you all the health.
I can put as many warnings
on it as possible,
but I can't stop me you
doing it, necessarily.
I can stop you from force
feeding Big Macs to children
because that's called abuse.
What I'm doing is I'm creating
a space where at least I
can get the children
out of the home
or into a safe space where they
can learn about the damages
that this can cause.
Over 18, you shouldn't do it.
Conversion therapy
is bad, it's harmful.
But I can always try to
warn you as a person who
will have to choose to go
through all of this red tape
and say OK, I want to
make this damage happen.
Under 18, you don't
have that option.
You never had that choice.
That's what I'm trying
to protect first.
I know we can have
a debate about that,
and I'm totally fine
with it, but that's
at least where we're starting.
Let's go with that space.
This is literally the best
week to be presenting this.
On Monday, for the very
first time in my life--
hopefully not the last,
because nuclear waste
is going to be solved
at some point--
I was interviewed
for Time Magazine.
We had the front page of Time
talking about the Born Perfect
campaign.
This is actually San Francisco.
This is the Golden
Gate Bridge Park,
and I actually went to
the same spot on Monday
just to remember what it
felt like to be there.
This is a campaign from
the National Center
of Lesbian Rights
specifically targeted
to end conversion therapy.
The first campaign of its kind.
There's no country
that has outlawed it,
but there are two
states which have,
and I'll talk a little
bit about those.
This is a space
where we can actually
start to have a conversation
about conversion therapy
on a national scale.
We can actually begin to
make this something that
is important and a conversation.
I will talk a little bit
more about Born Perfect
and I'm happy to
answer questions,
but I wanted you to know that
this finally becoming a space.
Our two successes far,
of many, is Senate Bill
112 here in California.
I'm literally
talking to the choir.
You're the very
first time I've ever
spoken about this in California.
It's the time that
I can actually say,
you've already done it.
Because no other state
has, really, so it's
been a lot of work.
You have actually made it
illegal for conversion therapy
to occur here in California.
To those of you who are
watching, you haven't.
You have work to do.
Or if you're watching
in California,
you're kind of-- anyway.
The second state that
we have made it illegal
is in New Jersey.
A Republican governor
and a Democratic governor
have both signed legislation
making this illegal.
This is a nonpartisan.
When this gets to a
vote, it is very hard
to say no, I really want
to shock my children.
That is not something that is
a very easy thing to argue.
Yes, there will be
arguments against us.
There will be First
Amendment issues
that they're going
to try to raise.
There are going to be
religious exemptions
that they're going
to try to raise.
But in general, when
we get this to a vote,
is pretty one-sided
that we're going to win.
The challenge is
just that we don't
have enough education about
people talking about this.
There are amazing other
survivors other than myself.
There are not a lot of us who
are able to speak about it.
Again, what I just went
through-- not to sound sad--
was traumatic.
I'm going to have
trauma tonight because
of what we talked about.
And that's OK, because
it's important space.
Other survivors do
the same exact thing,
but it is very hard
for us to do it
because we don't always
have the strongest
network of people
who support us.
There's Deb, who I just
met this weekend, and as
another person of
faith, is recognizing
that the traumas that
she was put through, yes,
happened in the name
of faith, but do not
represent that faith.
There's Ryan, who worked here
in California to pass the bill
and just graduated from
Columbia, a champion
among these spaces
who stands beside me.
We hug each other
knowing that it hurts,
and look at each
other saying, well,
we made it through another day.
There's Matthew, who's
working to currently get
the bill passed in New York
State, a man who recognizes
that the trauma that he went
through does define his path,
but does not define his
future and recognizes
that although he may have
had a horrible experience,
he can do great
things with his story.
These survivors like myself
are trying to get the word out
and are trying to
get the space out,
but there's not very
many of us and we
need people like you
to share our stories
and to share what is
going on, so that it
doesn't happen again.
Here's where we are.
You can see New Jersey
and California, orange,
which is, first of all, not
a beautiful color to wear.
I'm just, as your
fashion police,
be very careful with it.
Be very careful if you're
going to wear orange.
Anyway.
Sorry, dejection.
Orange, yay, states
that we've passed.
Green are states with
active legislation,
and yet even more are
considering legislation.
Each day, we have more and
more spaces with the National
Center for Lesbian Rights and
other organizations coalescing
to say, this has got to stop.
12 states alone this
legislative cycle
have added legislation
just considering it.
This is the definition of
the beginning of a movement,
and we're excited.
When I got the invitation
to come and speak,
this is exactly the spaces
that we can actually
start making a difference.
We can start taking
this story out there.
As you can see, they're
starting to take over.
We will, in five
years, have eradicated
this horrible torture.
Now it's your turn-- because I
went to a school that gave me
a lot of homework, so it's
my turn to give homework.
First, you need to tell
people about this session.
You can mention the
bright red stilettos.
You can mention the red mohawk.
I don't care what you say.
But you need to talk about
this awesome session-- well,
it was awesome.
There's other options.
It was an awesome session--
this awesome session
that you went to, and
then take the story out.
That's a very important space.
Talk about Born Perfect.
It just came out on Tuesday.
There's so much press
about it right now
that it's something
that you need
to be at this moment catalyzing.
Then, read an
article about this.
My story is one voice.
There's many other
voices out there,
and I want you to be able
to get a perspective of how
wide the range can be.
Also, I know that we're at
Google, but Facebook friends.
I have a public page where I
talk about all of these spaces.
Please go on and actually
check out the page and we'll
happily have a conversation.
This is my Gmail account.
I changed it this morning so
it wasn't my MIT email address.
I was like, ah yes.
This is how I'll
tailor it to you guys.
There you go.
You're welcome.
I would happily have a
conversation with you
also about these
kinds of spaces.
That's where we wrap up
the conversation here.
I'm looking forward
to your questions.
Like I said, please
don't make me just
stand up here looking pretty.
We'll obviously take questions
from the stream, as well.
Thank you for being here.
I hope that was helpful.
You can't choose
what you never chose,
but you can change
this horrible torture
to make sure it doesn't
happen to another child.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: My parents
didn't believe in therapy.
They sent me to a doctor.
They gave me hormones.
I had a hormone treatment
for like three years
that sent me up and
down, up and down
all the time until
I went to therapy.
The therapist was like,
you should get off
of all the medicines.
The law will include
something like that?
Or it's going to be just--
SAMUAL BRINTON: That
is a great question.
We talk a lot about therapies
that also-- and especially
in this legislation,
that identify
with gender identity-- I
would consider a good lawyer
would be able to connect that
forcing hormones onto someone
is probably somehow related
to how you're expecting
their gender expression or their
gender identity to coalesce.
I would say that in my
non-lawyer experience, that
is something that would
definitely be covered.
Because it's connected to
trying to change someone's
sexual orientation or
gender identity spaces.
There are stories like
this of overloading
a boy with testosterone
because you really
think it'll make him a man,
which, if you haven't guessed,
is not the best system
for your health.
Be very, very, very careful
as it's going through.
One, thank you for sharing
your experience, because that's
a very important thing and a
very hard thing, sometimes,
to share.
But yes, these
types of legislation
will help correct that.
Thank you for asking.
AUDIENCE: Also not a lawyer,
but the California law,
the way I was reading it,
said something specific
about mental health
professionals.
Does that wording
make it limiting?
Do you wish that
would be more broad?
SAMUAL BRINTON: This
is why I shouldn't just
have Sam up here.
The first space that I'll enter
would be yes, it is limiting.
That is partially how you get
some of these bills through,
is by limiting it to licensed
mental health professionals
and making that addressed.
Other conversations also start
to relate it to a responder.
Anyone like a librarian or
a teacher or someone that
can hear-- someone that is
forced to tell about abuse,
some of the legislation
is also starting
to address them, as well, saying
that this is not something--
if you hear about this and it's
not through a mental health
professional, at
least we can find you
and say no, that's something
we can protect against.
You can't take a license
away from someone
who doesn't have a license.
Religious organizations
will probably
practice this for
the rest of time,
unless I can figure
out a way to stop it.
I may not able to find
every little camp.
I may not be able to
find every pastor.
But I can make it something
that culturally is unacceptable.
Three years ago-- again, we wish
we would've screen shot this--
if you would have looked
up conversion therapy,
it would've been Exodus
International, the very first
one, with lists of providers.
Everything would've been
about these positive spaces
about how to get connected.
And now, it is holy crap,
this is a horrible thing.
It's illegal in two states.
It's much more difficult for
people to get access to it.
That's kind of the way
that I address this.
We actually have a
lawyer in the room,
so if I'm not
completely correct,
we can correct some
of those spaces.
But that's a space
that as I see it,
is that yes, it's directly
addressing mental health
professionals, but it's also by
proxy affecting everyone else
because it's getting
that reporting spin.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: It is correct.
SAMUAL BRINTON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said that in
the beginning, you loved God,
and you believed in God
and Jesus and all that.
How exactly has your
situation changed?
Has it altered it at all?
And if so, how did
you get through that?
SAMUAL BRINTON: Great question.
Definitely.
My degree is partially
in system dynamics.
This system has been quite
dynamic in my faith journey.
Initial therapy, why
does God hate me?
Post therapy, God hates
me, but at least I
can act like-- I had to
go to church every Sunday
anyway, so I might as
well act like the space.
Second coming out, where
I find that I'm not alone,
and I have been involved
in inter varsity.
I have been involved in
all of these organizations,
because that was my community
who then again turned
against me, and
that was last straw.
Like, come on, God.
You're not going to
do this twice to me.
I rejected, went to study
abroad in Shanghai, China,
and found an underground
church and realized
that these people were dying
for the faith that they held.
If something was that
important, maybe I
should least understand
why I rejected it.
And then starting to
have the study of whoa,
this is the concept
of man made religion
versus personal relationship.
That's how I started
to evolve and move to.
Ah, I just used
the word "evolved."
That's really funny.
I still don't
understand evolution.
I've been trained for many,
many years on how to refute it.
I'm an MIT graduate who doesn't
necessarily quite believe
in evolution, which is
really, really confusing.
Ah, but I just used
the word "evolved."
Yay.
Moving forward.
Or backward.
I don't know.
Heathen.
Liberal heathens, anyway.
The space for that, to
get back to your question,
is that currently
I live in a space
where I believe that
interpretation, in the past,
has been damaging
and that relationship
in the current and
future is enlightening.
I find it as a space where I
can connect, where I can center,
and where I can find a home.
That doesn't mean that I have to
be in a specific denomination.
I was raised Southern
Baptist and I still
feel the most comfortable
in Baptist churches,
but I can go to a Catholic
mass and sing beautiful music
and realize that that's
OK for me at that time.
I can go to a Unitarian
Universal Church
and see a message that is in
line with what I'm believing
because it's a
relationship space.
I know that this conversation
is kind of interesting
because it's about
conversion therapy,
but a lot of
conversation therapy
is centered around these
faith conversations,
so welcome to Google having
a lot of faith conversation
right now.
But that's an
important space for me.
It's good in my life.
I don't prescribe it
to others because I
don't want to force a
way of thought on others,
but don't take it away from me.
I think a big part
of the LGBT community
is so anti-faith because of
what has happened that they're
damaging their own
brothers and sisters
and non-identified individuals.
I should be able to
practice my faith.
That isn't something you
should be taking away from me.
You should be supporting.
OK, you found it.
Not for me, but you found it.
That's how I address
it right now.
It's not always easy.
I do personally
love also getting
into the arguments
about faith, because you
get a lot of battle.
I'm a missionary kid, so I can
quote a lot of these verses
in the original
Greek and Aramaic.
I can be like, OK, I just
quoted you the verse.
If you can translate that for
me, we can have a conversation.
OK, so we're done.
That's the space that
I'm at, in that you
have to study this issue.
You have to know what
you're talking about
rather than just being
told what to believe.
It is a personal moment,
and especially when
it comes to my sexual
orientation and my gender
identity, you don't get
to define it for a God
that you haven't talked to
about this specifically.
Yep, that's where I'm at.
AUDIENCE: This is
in no way meant
to be an attack or
anything like that.
I'm just speaking
towards inclusion.
I'm just curious, for the
Born Perfect message, which
I think is really bold
and captures this,
but does that really speak
to our trans friends?
SAMUAL BRINTON: A
great question, and one
that we've been getting
a little bit of.
We are born perfect
and we tell our story.
I'm sorry, we.
I sometimes identify in
that space, sometimes not.
So I won't speak as a member.
I will speak trying to
represent that space.
Trans individuals
are born perfect,
we just aren't
listening to them.
We're not hearing the stories
that they're telling us,
and we're not hearing that
what we're identifying them as
and what we're placing
on them is not perfect.
I feel that Born Perfect
captures that sentimentality,
that internally, we
are born perfect.
We're born the way
we're supposed to be.
We're just not
listened to sometimes.
Whether that be in
sexual orientation
or whether that be
in gender identity,
the stories aren't
getting heard.
This is a campaign to say no.
No longer.
Let them be who they are.
That's the way I would
address that question.
Thank you, again,
everyone, so much.
[APPLAUSE]